[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
war zone may only have been here a short
time but there are already numerous ways
to gain the edge in battle and hopefully
bring home more warzone victories and as
this game involves cross play it's
important to gain any and every edge in
battle we can especially if you're a
dirty casual like me but you still want
to be competitive
these tips are designed for controller
players and those playing on the console
but unsurprisingly all this works on PC
- so if you're ready here's 15 secrets
and settings to gain the edge in Call of
Duty warzone
let's start with controller tips and
tricks as a default setting we must hold
down square on ps4 and xboxone to pick
up any weapon this is not good enough
this slows us down and can make the
first weapon you find impossible to pick
up in time by the time you've held the
button down long enough your momentum
has gone too you become a sitting duck
therefore the first setting you should
change in your menus right away is this
go down to weapons and change use /
reload behavior - contextual tap this
will make things like opening crates and
picking up weapons and replacing weapons
all a single button press you will now
loot quicker and be on the move more
often oh and this carries over to
vehicles to get in them instantly it's
imperative when you're escaping the gas
or another team's ambush so do yourself
and your team a favor and switch to
contextual tap next by default our
character is set to run after pressing
on the left thumbstick this is fine and
all but once again the additional time
it takes to press that down can be
streamlined in your settings so jump
back into controller settings and down
to movement automatic sprint here we
have three options is disabled by
default
there's auto sprint and the one I
suggest is auto tactical sprint although
the difference between tactical sprint
and standard sprint is negligible at
this early point but definitely auto run
is a godsend so please use it
our next setting is film grain film
grain is here to make the game look more
cinematic as if it was filmed on exactly
that reel film or a cinema this adds a
filter over the image it's automatically
set quite low and does a great job of
hiding the lack of textures in some
areas when you're moving around the map
so by turning this off your game will
look a little less atmospheric and
you'll notice things like anti-aliasing
a little bit more but what you losing
visual film like aesthetic you will make
up invisibility buildings are easier to
maneuver around and spotting enemies at
all distances is another step easier the
film grain is a form of post-processing
which actually causes a minut delay on
your screen so turn off all
post-processing to gain the edge which
brings me to my next point motion blur
just like film grain motion blur is here
to make things look more cinematic
like and to hide a few unsightly issues
here's my advice jump into your settings
and under general and accessibility is
world motion blur and weapon motion blur
your game is most definitely going to
look worse but here's a thing to
remember have you ever watched a
professional PC player more often than
not the game actually looks better on
console but why is that well it's pretty
simple the pro always turns off
everything which doesn't benefit them
I'll distract them they turn off shadows
they turn off high-quality lighting they
turn off motion blur they want the bare
bones of the game with no
post-production or visual effects that
don't help them so let us take a page
out of their book and turn off our
motion blur the game will actually run a
little smoother on console now and when
quickly turning and aiming your target
acquisition will be improved greatly
okay so that was a little technical
let's find another way to get an
advantage here's a great simple one we
can change our hood options as a default
we have a circular mini-map this is
integral to knowing the enemy locations
well in general settings this can be
switched to a square shape instead and
it so happens to be far bigger and right
now bigger is better especially for this
bigger surface area more information on
screen their father trade-off is you
lose a little bit of your peripheral
vision but it's definitely worth it so
switch to square when you get the chance
also here's one which doesn't suit
everyone the mini-map can be locked in
place it won't rotate around if you're a
player or in a team who uses
north-south-east-west calls this screen
when locked in place is perfect
making north always up on the screen
each door is right south down and west
left like I said it's not for everyone
but if you use those call-outs this is a
good change our next setting is actually
three steps and it's all about the
Crouch button when you first play the
game this movement is set to be held
meaning we have to keep our thumbs down
for longer we've already established why
we don't like to hold buttons down it's
too time-consuming and this will get you
killed in the battlefield so under
controller settings go down to movement
and select slide behavior change this to
tap now you become John wick one button
epic slides let's go further into this
do you use a standard controller if so a
change I recommend will improve your aim
drastically in controller button layout
presets change default to tank
Pikul the change of Tiny's of here's the
theory your Crouch button is now located
on your right thumbstick
meaning every time you use Crouch or
slide your thumb will remain on the
stick this means you can aim whilst
crouching and sliding corner slides
become instinctive and sliding in
general becomes a huge part of the way
you maneuver around the map on a
negative side your Mele button is now
located on circle or beyond and Xbox I
think you may now lose punch fights but
let's be honest what do you use more
crouch or melee I'm gonna guess you use
crouch by the way PlayStation gamers I'm
currently reviewing the ps4 back buttons
which are a super cheap alternative to a
full-blown scuf controller so far e7 is
quite an impressive piece of kit
allowing two paddles to be set
underneath in Call of Duty games scuff
and other paddle based systems have a
huge advantage over us as they can jump
and shoot in the same motion but a
normal human being will struggle to do
this with a standard controller unless
you play claw of course but I won't go
into why you shouldn't play claw so now
we can change this to mimic the sliding
function we had earlier the paddles
underneath can now be used for any
button at all whichever you want which
means your fingers underneath the
controller are doing the work and not
your thumbs coming off the thumbsticks
so yeah these things are awesome
I also recommend the strike pack which
is on ps4 and Xbox if you don't want to
spend too much but you want to
experience paddle based gaming anyway
I'll try and review these as soon as
possible so please keep an eye on the
channel
I think low cost options are a great
thing for all of us here's a
super-secret thing you can do to gain a
huge advantage but it will take a bit of
time to master switching aim and fire to
the shoulder buttons and off the
triggers so on a ps4 that's r2 to r1 l2
to l1 it's hidden in plain sight
simply press square on any layout you
want and the shoulder buttons and
triggers will switch places it sounds
wrong on so many levels doesn't it but
here's the science the triggers take a
little bit longer to press down than the
buttons do so by switching these you can
gain a split-second edge in a gunfight
it could be the difference between dying
and living so it depends how tryhard you
want to be FYI once you've made this
change in this game it's so difficult to
switch back to other games so remember
you can change this setting permanently
on your consoles based settings look for
accessibility and in there you will be
able to switch any button around you'd
like there's actually a version of this
control system in Call of Duty warzone
right now the closest setting to
replicate both of these points are the
bumper jumper tactical flipped presets
mouth pop but once again it will take
even longer to learn there's pros and
cons to everything here aim and fire I
moved forward to the front buttons where
a jump is now matched to the left
trigger l2 and Crouch is on the
thumbstick this means with practice
you'll get the advantage of instant fire
the advantage of jumping without taking
your thumb of the sticks and the
advantage of slide shooting without
moving your thumb also this is god-tier
but all my word it's hard to learn I
gave up and went back to using paddles
i'm a sell-out let's get back to the
melee fights we were speaking of
especially in the gulag here's a great
quick tip turn off your control of
vibration getting fisted in the prison
is one of the most annoying things ever
especially when the vibration is on so
turn that off it will also calm you down
before your gulag fight it also has real
in-game ramifications to the rumble
function yeah it's a great way to feel
part of the game but the problem is
during that buzz in your hands you are
impacted making aiming and shooting
harder you're fighting uncontrollable
movement so get that switched off to
regain your composure and also the
rumble function is being investigated as
a contributor to arm vibration syndrome
and you definitely don't want to get
that no proven truth just yet though so
don't jump to any conclusions another
setting you should consider is the auto
move forward I personally do not use
this but I can see the benefits of
letting you see it for yourself just
like in many games auto move asks you to
press in the direction you'd like to go
twice in quick succession then the
controller will take over and continue
your momentum I don't like this because
I accidentally use it too often and just
walk away from my cover but you should
know this whilst Auto running with your
squad you can look at your items in your
inventory knowing that you're always
pushing forward you can drop items by
your friends or just check what ammo you
need if you play with friends Auto run
is very useful but it's definitely not
everyone call of duty war zone can be a
very dark a game which is quite gray at
times I've been playing around with the
color blindness modes and got to admit
to add extra vivid colors to the game I
recommend ultra no Pia
or whatever the hell it's called it's
not just for people with colorblind
deficiencies just look how much the
world pops with this maybe I've been
playing for tonight for too long and
prefer vibrant colors of a beige and
gray it's just a suggestion but if he's
thinking why in some of these videos it
looks more vibrant that's the reason at
this point I had planned to give you a
definitive answer on the audio settings
you should use in war zone but I'll be
straight to it I can't decide which is
best yet it's not great when you compare
it to something like apex Legends so
don't expect the same clarity and
directional Intel here but here's what I
figured out thus far when using
headphones choose one of the boost
options low frequency is superior for
hearing footsteps if you're the kind of
player who prioritizes that above all
else and the boost high setting will
give you a superior mix in general as
well as keeping those footsteps pretty
loud in the audio mix a general tip here
is to completely ditch the music audio
as it's a distraction and another tip is
to lower the dialogue volume slightly
around 20% by doing this you'll still be
able to hear the announcer who gives you
heads up on UAVs and that sort of thing
but it won't interfere with the most
important section of all the ingame
sound the bullets the footsteps the
vehicles the effect volume is king here
and for those who are always interested
in sensitivity of other players let's
break it down now by default our
controller is set to 4 for in the world
of college duty this is the most used
setting there is that's why they call it
default but unlike many other games war
zone has a crazy amount of
differentiation so generalizing 1 2 3 is
classed as low sense 4 to 6 is medium
sense and 7 and above is high sense and
there's even one called insane I'd love
to know if you can win again with that
my personal setting is 5 5 slap in the
middle of the sensitivity here's a note
though if I only played war zone and
nothing else I'm sure my setting would
be 77 or maybe higher by now because
muscle memory kicks in and the finesse
of your thumbs is increased the more you
play a certain type of game but I'm not
a guy who can do that so
right in the middle here's the pros and
cons really quickly low sensitivity is
all about bigger movements with your
thumbs it's primarily for heavy-handed
people or if you play in a very cold
room low sensitivity is for you the
benefits are accuracy at range it's
extremely easy to track anyone at range
with a low sensitivity but here's the
negative point you'll be very easy to
hit when you're trying to maneuver
around the level not your running speed
that will be the same but when you move
left and right and try to weave and duck
you won't do it at the same speed as a
high cent player on the flip side of
that let's look at those high sense
players these guys use tiny thumb
movements to make huge changes on screen
on the plus side they can dodge bullets
they can move that quickly sneaking
around and up close and personal they
can hit so many shots when it comes to
distance though people on high senses
usually struggle to hit shots at
distance which leads me to ad s sense so
this is you're aiming down sight
regardless of if you play low medium or
high cents you can micromanage your
sensitivity when aiming for example
you'll regularly see a high cent player
with an incredibly low abs sent to
combat they're ranged issues and they'll
tend to hipfire and close up so as a
starting point I recommend staying in
medium sensitivity and looking to slowly
progress to higher sensitivity the pros
definitely outweigh the cons so adjust
yourself over time if you can try and
get that number a little bit higher it's
all personal preference no one can tell
you what to do but that's a general
understanding of sensitivity
I do hope that helped okay we don't
understa thank you very much hopefully
that helped in some way shape or form if
it did alike would be appreciated but at
this point no one ever stays till yet if
you did stay till the end can you write
I found a soap MacTavish easter egg I am
Adam from PlayStation Renae thank you so
much me time I'll see you soon
[Music]